wer vor 500 jahren mit so einem schuss
getroffen wurde hatte nichts mehr zu
lachen doch das mittelalter bestand
nicht nur aus krieg rüstung und
bogenschießen auf kalte nächte hat es
essen und kilometer weite meer steht zur
quelle gehörten dazu das alles können
wir uns heute mit leitungswasser heizung
handy und internet natürlich kaum
vorstellen aber microsoft hat mit dem
gelegenheit gegeben diese raue
vergangenheit einmal am eigenen leib zu
erfahren und mich für age of empires 4
auf eine zeitreise in das mittelalter
eingeladen von freitag bis sonntag gibt
es kein handy kein kunststoff kein strom
kein fließend wasser und keine heizung
bei drei grad nachts also wie hat man im
mittelalter gelebt und wie wirkt sich
das auf einen verweichlichten menschen
der neuzeit aus
dieses video wird unterstützt von age of
empires 4 das spiel gibt es jetzt im
microsoft store auf steam und xbox game
pass link dazu in der video beschreibung
herzlich willkommen im mittelalter alles
was ich ab sofort an klamotten oder an
decken oder sogar sein findet sich hier
drin und wurde so auch im mittelalter
verwendet und als erstes muss ich jetzt
mal meine modernen klamotten loswerden
und die authentischen anziehen
ich habe mich im gewand gehüllt andere
was ich noch mal in besitz nehmen kann
sind meine wollte sie wäre ich jetzt
auch gleich brauchen denn die sonne geht
unter und wir bauen gerade noch für
andere dunkelheit das zelt in dem wir
schlafen werden und dann gemerkt
[Musik]
ich hoffe nicht dass die mich damit rum
schießen wollen also es gibt vier wände
dies kann man sagen ja ja das ist
richtig schwer ja
wie schwer kann ein stück stoff denn
sein
hier eigentlich so man stadtbewohner wer
neidisch
[Musik]
weiter geht's
jetzt hat jemand morgens waren dass sich
ihr selbst euer
leben mit leute nach jetzt regnet doch
etwas doch egal oder also alles noch mal
von vorne die lager gruppe die mich
familie aufgenommen und mir zum glück
eines ihrer zelte bereit gestellt hat
heißt die hund linke mit ihnen werde ich
die nächsten tage hier arbeiten und
leben gemeinschaft sowie auch die eine
gute ausrüstung und dicke schaffelle
sind in diesen schweren zeiten
unverzichtbar vor allem da man von
eisigen drei grad munkelt auf die es
heute nach dem abkühlen soll bis jetzt
ist mir noch nicht kalt nachts mal
runter gehen und da ist natürlich dann
auch nicht in bewegung und aber gerade
klamotten
top
[Musik]
während wir zur anbruch der dunkelheit
noch immer fleißig mit dem zeltaufbau
beschäftigt sind werden wir bereits
hungrig durch den geruch des kochens das
zelt steht derzeit auf platz 4 und wird
jetzt gerade essen gemacht aber davor
habe ich gehört gibt es leckeres mit ich
habe gehört dass es nicht sein könne
hahn ist folgert das ist dass schnaps
nicht ob das ist voll geil weil das ist
voll geil er ist kriegt die kleinste
schützt das
holz dafür einfach ja noch nie gegessen
[Musik]
seit 1
die schon jetzt gras für ein feuer ohne
angst im material geht gar nichts die
kleinteile ist sie ganz gläubiger
einteilen wir müssen langsam anfangen
nicht steigern uns von klein auf grußlos
probieren ich wünsch' probieren kann
[Musik]
dauern so ist
das feuer brennt nicht warm anbietet
feuermachen im mittelalter ist echt ne
knifflige angelegenheit ein paar funken
konnte ich zwar schlagen aber erst mit
der hilfe der anderen hat das stroh
richtig angefangen zu glimmen so dass es
danach durch unermüdliches pusten erst
zu einem kleinen dann zu einem großen
feuer entfachen konnte das uns allen
wärme spendet
[Musik]
das dürfte jetzt ungefähr mitternacht
sei nicht schlafen und bruder gesagt hat
es ziemlich kalt dann gute nacht sehr
wohl noch so vier grad kriegen denn
ziemlich viel schafswolle ich hab hier
padeken mal schauen ich hoffe ich dann
durch schlaf und das nicht gleich gut
nachgesetzt gerade 32 ländern ungefähr
heimischen nachweisen bisschen kalt
geworden ich weiß nicht woran es liegt
ich habe nochmal extra schafsfell geholt
und jetzt kuschelig mich um ein und dann
soll es eigentlich das ist echt das
restliche welt ich brauche euch das mal
eine viertelstunde um mich einzuwickeln
kalt aber jetzt ging es
aber mir so das ticket schafsfell dann
haben wir uns für über kopf zu bewahren
zu schützen ich befinde mich auf den
zulagen wieder essen zubereitet und
wärme ist vorüber es war ja schon wieder
gut
damit sie ein üppiges kräuter aufgebot
als goody hat hier in der gegend wachsen
gefüllt wurden nicht von uns ich denke
das könnte gegen einzelne minister oder
ich weiß ich hab citrus oder orangen
oder irgendwas mit ist
und dass ich auch das passt schon mal
ganz gut weil sie viele kräuter zugibt
und dort ist hier auch eigentlich nur
kräuter zum würzen sein treffer waren
ziemlich teuer ziemlich teuer das ist
auch sehr cool gleichzeitig würde mir
jetzt auch nicht in den beeten klopfen
aber
viel zu essen folgt noch nie probiert es
erstmal dass wir sagen ich möchte
nämlich für meinen verweichlichten
geschmack schon ein bisschen bitter
jetzt die marvin und die liste und
brenner ist natürlich noch mal sagen
sagt perfekt wir sind unterwegs oder mal
wasser rein ich glaube die kritik kalt
und richter finden wir super gut
gelöst wird hier natürlich nicht
das heißt richtig schön von innen auf
das ist gut und jetzt gehen wir gleich
für das frühstück noch mal zur obstwiese
haben uns ein paar äpfel oder vielleicht
auch bieren
obstwiesen keiner geholt wenn wir sparen
was zu finden
habt ihr schon bald wird der firma augen
von die brennesseln bietet aber
sie können uns glauben nicht aufweist
[Musik]
also hier gibt es nur auf menschen sind
also vielleicht sind sogar zu sammeln
das ist natürlich nicht im supermarkt
ein paar davon sehen auch schon
jetzt
haben sich die reifen geschäftsnamen
gesucht
ich bin gesandter von age of empire um
die frohe kunde von teil 4 zu verkünden
und da ist sagen wir natürlich auch
essenziell wichtig aber natürlich wird
den neuen age of empires vier nicht nur
gesammelt sondern ganz wie in den ersten
teilen auch in epischen schlachten um
den sieg gekämpft im neuesten teil habt
ihr die auswahl aus acht verschiedenen
völkern alle mit ihren eigenen stärken
und schwächen denn auch in der echten
welt sah das mittelalter in asien
natürlich komplett anders aus als zum
beispiel in europa in den schlachten
geht es dann darum schere stein papier
prinzip die richtigen truppen
einzusetzen wie zum beispiel kavallerie
gegen bogenschützen wo wir auch schon
direkt beim nächsten tagesordnungspunkt
wären einer der wichtigsten einheiten in
age of empires ist der bogenschütze und
das schauen jetzt mal an ich werde das
ist ja erst modul ist hier nichts zu tun
ja doch sie sind und damit trifft das
die dinge mit denen du an das image
israels der superleichte das stell dich
mal so hin dass du seitlich stößt genau
in die linke hand ziehst du bist du in
deinem mund wenn die best da und das
einfach los und wenn du hinten bist am
besten dass du mit fingerspitzen und
dann ist ja und machst dann nur die
fingerspitzen auf harte gangart noch
vorreiter ist der mund ist weiter
das schwache bogen
jetzt getroffen hat trotzdem weh aber
ich habe waffen nehme ich jetzt einfach
ein bisschen wie sich das team treff und
macht ja nix los wenn es nicht triffst
wenn das jetzt weiß nicht ein elefant
wäre dann hätte er jetzt ein fall drin
steckt macht man da ein auge zu oder so
da aber weiß ich nicht und versuche mal
grundsätzlich tiefe zu ziehen also sehr
gut aussieht
das passt felix
[Musik]
okay da ist nicht nötig aber er ist er
hat auch über den getroffen er war
richtig sehen also das ding hat auch
immer eine gut gemachte absage
bogenschießen habe ich direkt gemeinsam
spaß aber ich hätte nicht gedacht dass
ich selbst das teil treffen werde und
dann ist auch endlich das essen fertig
was sie tatsächlich sehr geil aus das
sieht wirklich okay ist es ja bereich
aber es ist ja gerade aus kleine
kostprobe
ja gut schmeckt halt super und süß 1 war
aber den folk stücken slacker wir haben
auch nicht begeistert und während wir
unser mittelalterliches frühstück noch
auf essen wird schon das essen für den
abend vorbereitet acht ganze hühner soll
es geben während fleisch essen zu können
heute normal ist ist dieses essen im
mittelalter sicherlich ein festmahl aber
nicht nur die art der essence
beschaffung war eine andere auch das
wasser gab es noch nicht im supermarkt
und den supermarkt auch noch nicht wir
gehen jetzt in den berg hoch
wohnungswesen wasser von der quelle
minister man könnte ja jeder zeit im
hinterhalt irgendwie erlischt werden von
den schmerzen also ein bisschen gewicht
das mikro bestände
[Musik]
es ist ziemlich schwer reines wasser zu
finden nicht nur wenn man wie ich
erschöpft vom training ist deshalb haben
sich die meisten dörfer und städte im
mittelalter an flüssen oder zumindest in
der nähe von quellen gebildet wo sie
heute immer noch stehen haben sich
gefunden wie sieht es nicht gut aus wie
ich mir oft hatte dass ich jetzt nicht
nehmen
hier folgt und geht volk das recht gut
mein training geht weiter nichts bringt
man mehr in verbindung mit dem
mittelalter als ritter in schillernden
rüstungen aber kann ein schwächling wie
ich überhaupt in so einem super schweren
stahl panzer laufen und tut es
eigentlich trotzdem wählen so eine
rüstung geschlagen zu werden oder steckt
man das alles einfach weg
erst mal knapp
ein leben alleine anziehen ist nicht
der vergiftungen sind übrigens perfekt
klimatisiert im winter ist es kalt dafür
sind im sommer sowie
bewegungsfreiheit ist eingeschränkt also
jetzt um seinen schon ein yoga wird
jetzt nichts mehr mussten knappen auch
dann quasi gegen krieg ziehen oder waren
die wirklich nur als assistent der
knappe war quasi der ritter und
ausbildung
also ich fühle mich schon auf jeden fall
stand haben aber nochmal eine kette
verletzlichsten teile diese rüstung
bezüge menschen
schulterbereich und
ganz
von unten
also darin laufen sich schon recht
eingeschränkt wo alter ist ein handwerk
ja
also es ist definitiv wirklich sehr sehr
schwer ungefähr 45 kilo tor
dann würde sagen ich probiere es mal war
ein ritter muss ich ja viel bewegen im
zweifel auch schnell ist es jetzt mal ob
es überhaupt realistisch ist für mich
also es geht aber
ich glaube also wirklich jetzt mehr als
eine umdrehung
ich hier um die distribution
halte ich für nicht möglich
welche betätigungen gab sonst noch so im
mittelalter außer ritter sein weil dann
würde ich mir die lieber noch mal
anschauen
meine schultern von w form stehen
als hätte ich dies wird an
sehr luftig auch luftig ist wenn jetzt
die falken seine was anschauen werden
super überleitungen danke thomas wegener
zum falken auf dem weg entdecke ich aber
erst mal ein kleines arsenal an
belagerungswaffen die natürlich direkt
von mir fachmännisch getestet werden
wer nicht lange
bis das crazy ja ich habe schon einmal
schießt werde ich mir denn je davon
stehe
okay und auf geht's los
macht schon spaß ich verstehe wieso er
die dinger baut oder hund
komplett verrückte aus einen
belegungsplan ich würde man jetzt weise
irgendwie lagern da seine rammbock ein
echter rammbock sind ungefähr vier leute
würden dann quasi das ding nach vorne
und auch hinten schubsen damit das
traktor ein originaler rammbock also man
kann sich hier bewegen also ich glaube
ich würde auch ein bisschen schon
hinkriegen das heißt kann sichert vier
man bräuchte dann auch um das ganze ding
hier zu china hat ja auch wieder das
teilte seine klappe die clubs dann
können deine männer quasi in dieburg die
anderen gehen diese zeiten da die haben
sich dann in der mauer ein und dann
vorbei mit den belagerten diese und noch
viel mehr belagerung einheiten stehen
euch auch natürlich in age of empire
stil zur verfügung wenn es darum geht
die städte eurer gegner zu erobern und
bisher alle gemeistert habt ihr erlebt
die etliche stunden spielspaß denn nicht
nur hat der singleplayer-modus 40
missionen in denen ihr die einzelnen
truppen und völker kennenlernen könnt
sondern auch einen online multiplayer
modus in dem ihr dann euren eigenen
spielstil auf die probe stellen können
egal ob er mit den kriegselefanten der
delikaten vorprescht oder es eher
defensiv angeht und auch die
widerstandsfähigen gebäude des heiligen
römischen reiches setzt dank der
verschiedenen völker individuellen
einheiten und gebäude gibt es unzählige
wege age of empire vier zu spielen und
strategisch vorzugehen wodurch jeder auf
seine kosten kommt ihr könnt sogar
falken zur aufklärung losschicken was im
echten leben etwas beängstigend ist als
das erstmal so klingen mag wie wir
ängstigen finde ich jetzt heraus als
nächstes geht es für uns mit dem falkner
nämlich auf die bei ca eine aktivität
die ich nur erleben kann weil ich hier
ja zum glück ein hoher gast und kein
einfacher werben die ausbildung eines
vogels hat so viel zeit und geld
gekostet das nur adlige es sich leisten
konnten das ganze als eine art frühen
luxus sport entweder selbst zu betreiben
oder einen schon ausgebildeten vogel von
einem falkner zu kaufen dabei waren gute
jagd bürgel mehr wert als ihr gewicht in
gold dass dieser preis durchaus nicht
übertrieben war sieht man ein steinadler
ludwig mit dem wir im wald unterwegs
waren er ist gerade mal 2,5 kilo schwer
hat aber schon mal ein 20 kilogramm
liegt was mich durchaus etwas beunruhigt
die hand in hand filmdreh nochmal kasten
danach nicht danach das musst du bist
nur über gäste zwei fest und da hast du
vor dem abschluss
[Musik]
das ist normal wenn er bei gelandet und
susanne federn überstürzt reise
will das ding ist das nicht dass das
ludwig auch bei mir einfach so landet
liegt daran dass jagd für die eigentlich
keine sozialen tiere sind sie lernen in
einem langen prozess dass ihnen auf dem
falken handschuh keine gefahr droht und
sie dort sogar jede menge futter
bekommen dadurch wird ihnen stück für
stück beigebracht mitmenschen als team
zusammenzuarbeiten
[Musik]
crazy das ist komplett vom kunden möchte
los zwischen geschichte und
kann so ein paar heute ist wenn der so
gut trainiert das ist natürlich ganz
hinter dem pferd
[Musik]
entweder wird
das meinst also wird das ist gesund
junge ist das krasseste heute mal die
faust in
die hand hoch er geht immer zum höchsten
punkt und übung land
genauso
wie
vor sich her dann schau der größe genau
aber als nächstes steht der wohl größte
nervenkitzel an bevor wir aber
felsbrocken mit dem trio steht durch die
luft schleudern können muss es erstmal
gespannt werden mit der muskelkraft von
vier menschen da das laufen im rat sehr
gefährlich ist war ich am anfang extrem
angespannt was man glaube ich in meinem
gesicht sie die größte gefahr ist es zu
stolpern und dann vielleicht zwischen
die speicher zu kommen die dann nicht
auf einen warten wird oder durch die
anstrengungen ohnmächtig zu werden es
soll wohl schon passiert sein dass leute
das gleichgewicht verloren haben und als
folge in dem rad herumgeschleudert
wurden während das laufen am anfang noch
ziemlich einfach ist wird es zum ende
hin immer schwerer und schwerer je
weiter man die circa 5 tonnen gewicht in
die luft gehoben hat sobald die stahl
sense die als auslöser für das drehbuch
diente über den wurf angelegt wurde
müssen die räder die an diesem haken
befestigt sind noch gelöst werden
weshalb man ein stück rückwärts gehen
muss
dann werden die räder gesichert und das
drehbuch ist geladen
also am ende ging es ganz gut
irgendwann hat man dann auch den wert
aus
ein wenig neben rechtsanwalt
aber ganz
schon jetzt mal gespannt wie gleich
erdebeben wird wenn die 34 tonnen hier
100 tonnen war jetzt will auch was gutes
spannendes alles
ist das will
ist das kräftig einfach das ist wie auch
immer das jetzt abgekriegt hat wir haben
die schlacht gewonnen wir gehen jetzt
ein findling suchen
da ist nicht mal im kader das ist heftig
also wenn man hier steht
ja es hat nicht gut und hinten ist der
kollege der einladen bei einer echten
belagerung hat man sich natürlich nicht
seine steine am bollerwagen wieder
geholt aber trotzdem dauerte es
schätzungsweise immer eine halbe stunde
bis das drehbuch wieder gespannt beladen
und feuer bereit war und dieses mal
nehmen wir feuern übrigens wörtlich
[Musik]
der ja
[Applaus]
das noch
das internet ablaufen
das ist auch in siegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das drehbuch ist tatsächlich die grösste
präziseste und vor allem mächtigste
waffe des mittelalters stellt euch mal
vor was für einen schaden man mit
mehreren dieser belagerung maschinen an
den mauern einer stadt oder burg
verursachen konnte
das saugen wir heftig aus und so endet
mein abenteuer im mittelalter und auch
wenn es ein wahnsinnig spannender und
interessanter trip in die vergangenheit
war bin ich doch froh wieder in die
gegenwart zurückzukehren zum glück kann
man jetzt aber auch zu hause am pc die
unterschiedlichsten epochen nach erleben
und in age of empire ist 4 sogar
anführer einer solchen zivilisation sein
wenn jetzt also auch bock auf das
mittelalter bekommen habt klickt auf den
link in der beschreibung und holt euch
das neue age of empires für mich wird es
damit zeit mich ans nächste verrückte
experiment zu wagen nachdem wir uns dann
wiedersehen wenn ihr nicht abonniert
haben
[Musik]